من ابرز المدن الاوكرانيه المتضرره من
المعارك في منطقه خرسون هي مدينه نيكولايف
التي لا تبعد سوى 60 كيلومترا فقط في خط
مستقيم عن مدينه خرسون مدينه نيكولايف
المينائيه تتعرض للقصف اليومي والمكثف
طيله الاشهر الثمانيه الماضيه ومع
الانسحاب الروسي من مدينه خرسن الا ان
التساؤل بتهدئه التوتر لا يزال حذرا
ونسبيا لدى سكانيه
اذان
واعتقد انه سيكون من الاسهل العيش لكن
مازلنا خائفين
من الضرب
لكن الخطر يكمل في ان يبدا المعتدي الروسي
في الانتقام مما حصل
لا يزال قائما ايضا لدى السلطات المحليه
لمدينه
بالنسبه اليها انسحاب القوات الروسيه الى
الضفاف الشرقيه لنهر النيورو لا يعني
بالضروره توقف الهجمات الروسيه بالصواريخ
والقذائف من اقليم خرسون نحو مدينتي لايف
لانه هناك مسافه كبيره بين من كليب
والقوات الروسيه لكن لا احد بالسطاعته ان
يضمن ذلك على سبيل المثال تم شنه هجوم
صاروخيه هنا يوم الجمعه ادى الى مقتل سبعه
اشخاص وتدمير
الكثير من التحديات لا تزالوا تواجه
السلطات المحليه في ميكو لايف بدءا باعاده
البناء ونزع الالغام من محيط المدينه
وخاصه العمل على اعاده امداد الماء الصالح
للشرب من خلصن هذا الماء المنقطع على
مدينه ميكورايس منذ عده اشهر وذلك بسبب
التواجد الروسي في منطقه